[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilshire host and our guest is
Marsha Seon horn
she's the William K lamb and professor
of anthropology and international
affairs at Yale University and a former
president of the Society for medical
anthropology of the American
Anthropological Association professor in
horn is the author of many award-winning
books including the new Arab man and
cosmopolitan conceptions IVF so germs
and global Dubai today we'll talk with
professor in Hoorn about her new book
America's Arab refugees vulnerability
and health on the margins
welcome professor Ann horn thank you I'm
very pleased to be here yes it's great
to have you on again so let's talk about
your newest book tell us about it
yeah this book is probably the first
anthropological account of the situation
facing Arab refugees who have come into
the United States over the past decades
and it's a book that really explains the
difficulties and why people fled from
the Middle Eastern region because of all
the conflict that's been going on in the
region you know again for decades and
this book is called America's Arab
refugees because in a way my main goal I
think is to show how America's
involvement in conflict in the Middle
Eastern region has in fact led to
overwhelming problems of refugee flight
especially from the countries of Iraq
and Afghanistan and not an Arab country
but a Middle Eastern country the wars
that are really ongoing in those
countries and then obviously the crisis
now in Syria and increasingly in Yemen
so that there really are some serious
conflicts in which America is involved
that have led to the flight of millions
of Arab refugees
and only a very small percentage of them
are getting into the u.s. but they're
here and this book really looks at what
happens to Arab refugees in this country
okay and a lot of your work is done
overseas with this show this book really
is centered in the United States what
led you to pursue this yeah to be honest
I was never really intending to write a
book about Arab refugees in America but
they were a population that I discovered
in a project that took place between an
anthropological study in Lebanon and an
anthropological study in the United Arab
Emirates and during a period of about
five years I ended up going back and
forth to what is probably the largest
Arab ethnic Enclave community in America
which is in the greater metropolitan
Detroit Michigan the city of Detroit and
particularly an area called Dearborn
which scholars have dubbed Arab Detroit
because there are as many as 400,000
maybe even 1/2 million Arabs living in
this part of this part of Detroit and I
was working in a health clinic in
Dearborn and most of the people that I
started seeing and I started talking to
were actually men and women who had fled
from war zones
you know many were Iraqi refugees who
had come either from the first Gulf War
or the war that started in 2003 that the
u.s. started in 2003 or they were from
the southern parts of Lebanon and had
fled during that long conflict that
started in 1975 and Lebanon and lasted
until the year 2000 so they these were
people who had fled they were living in
Michigan and frankly most of them were
not doing that well sort of economically
they were facing a lot of hardship as
refugees in this country so let's talk
about the methodology you used for the
book I know you did a lot of interviews
tell us about that yes so we
anthropologists we have sort of two ways
we call our methodology ethnography
which is really either you know
interviews very in-depth interviews with
people sometimes hour-long
hours long interviews and a lot of what
we call purchase of an observation
hanging about and sort of participating
with people as they're going about their
daily lives and so in this study I
worked with almost a hundred Arab men
and women mostly men actually and they
were all presenting at a clinic in
Dearborn that was really an Arab serving
clinic the physician there was an Arab
spoke Arabic and they were coming in
this case because they had serious
reproductive health problems rather
daunting problems that required a lot of
intervention and a lot of money that
most of them really could ill afford so
I was really looking at how you know in
America our health care system which is
a private health care system where you
have to pay for your health care
services was really not serving this
very vulnerable refugee population
people who were basically impoverished
and something that we forget about is
the level of poverty in a lot of
American big cities Detroit as a city is
considered to be the poorest big city in
America yet it has taken in a
disproportionate share of the arab
refugee population in fact the three
states that have the highest number of
Arab refugees are California then
Michigan and Texas and so a state that
has its own economic problems is in a
way trying to cope with a huge influx of
refugees that are either getting placed
there or who choose to migrate there
because there is a sort of Arab
community to which they can you know
belong mm-hmm so in talking to these men
and some women what were some of the
trends that you saw most of these men
had been through horrific things in the
wars you know some had lived under
Saddam Hussein he had been conscripted
into the army some had spent years in
prison some had been tortured some had
fled their family members had been
killed they fled often with very little
some of the Iraqis had fled through
Saudi Arabia and were placed in refugee
camps in Saudi Arabia before they made
their way to the United States and so
they had been through some grueling
you know and difficult and health
demoting circumstances and the book
really looks at what are the health
costs of conflict what happens to people
physically mentally you know
infrastructurally what happens to
families when they're forced to flee
because of a conflict and really my book
shows all of these detrimental sort of
circumstances that people bring with
them in a way when they come to the
states and then the book really looks at
resettlement in America and how the US
has or has not really put in sufficient
effort into refugee resettlement
interestingly after the Vietnam War
there were hundreds of thousands of
Vietnamese refugees who made their way
to this country and in those days back
in the early 1980s the US government did
do its best to support you know
Vietnamese families they often got three
years of cash assistance they were
helped to get jobs they were helped to
get their lives you know up and running
and over the years the sort of
assistance given to refugees has just
gotten less and less and less now
refugees are lucky if they get eight
months of cash assistance they're told
to get jobs immediately because they
need to be you know self-sufficient
before a years out and so they often end
up in very low paying minimum-wage jobs
they often are scraping by and so they
end up in a situation of real chronic
poverty they never really can get off
the ground often they have skills that
they bring with them some of the people
I worked with who had been engineers
they had been professionals in their
home countries they come to the United
States and they're working as Busboys
and restaurants or you know they're not
working and professional they get no
recertification they often don't have
English because they don't get time to
get English language skills down so it's
a it the term that we used in medical
anthropology is structural vulnerability
these people because of their position
in society coming as refugees no English
low-income you know sometimes poor
educational backgrounds very little
money no social support systems living
in a city that's impoverished they are
very vulnerable and they often there lie
end up being fairly vulnerable as they
go along it wasn't all you know
unfortunate stories there were a few
people in my study who had actually done
surprisingly well and I tried to sort of
showcase the sort of hope and aspiration
and desire for a new life a better life
in America you know you tell the story
about one of them yeah there was a man I
call him Kemal that was not his you know
real name but he was fortunate in that
he had come with his two brothers there
were three he had been in the Army under
Saddam Hussein he had seen horrific
things he had survived and he fled with
his two brothers and they were all
placed together as a sort of group of
three brothers in you know this Detroit
community and together because the three
of them sort of supported each other
they were able to slowly sort of make a
life he ended up eventually owning two
small businesses they bought two small
fixer-upper homes and so they sort of
began achieving the American dream of
home ownership of it being a small
business entrepreneur and he was able to
accrue enough money he had a very
serious male infertility problem which
who knows it could have been related to
the sort of toxic exposures of the Iraq
war but he ended up being able to use
technology it's a variant of in vitro
fertilization that helped him to have a
baby with his wife and it was expensive
I mean to do that technology in America
usually costs more than twelve thousand
US dollars he had his one shot of doing
it and he was very lucky to have a baby
so he was a happy person you know he
told me his story you know showed me the
pictures of his son and he was you know
what I would call a sort of a refugee
success story and I have to say here in
New Haven we have an amazing sort of
community of support for Refugees
through iris our refugee resettlement
agency Yale through the legal services
of Yale the medical services of Yale
Medical School and so there are refugees
especially from Iraq and increasingly
from Afghanistan and Syria who are
coming here and are beginning to sort of
shape their lives and I can name success
stories right here in the Yale system so
refugees can do well but I would our
you in my book that the majority are
vulnerable very structurally vulnerable
and they have a lot of health problems
that are just not being dealt with in
your book could you offer suggestions on
what we can do in this country to
improve the situation of not only Arab
refugees but other refugees yeah I
believe and I think this is maybe my
strongest message of the book is that
America has a moral responsibility to
refugees especially refugees coming from
countries in which America started the
wars that led to the displacement and
the destroyed lives of people and for me
the wars that really matter in this
millennium are the war in Iraq and the
war in Afghanistan and America is also
very much involved from the air at least
in terms of dropping American armaments
on Syria on Yemen on Libya the places
that are war zones in the Middle East
and so if you make a war and you break a
country you have a responsibility for
fixing the country and fixing the lives
of people you know whose lives you've
destroyed and I think others share my
sentiments we have a moral
responsibility to refugees from
countries where we've you know we
started wars and so for me I think the
main story of this book is the Iraqi
refugee story that we never talk about
anymore because you know Iraq the war
was started what in 2003 supposedly it
ended in 2011 but it really hasn't ended
they're still American troops on the
ground in that country there's still
people fleeing that country the three
major groups of refugees coming out of
the Middle East are from Syria Iraq
Afghanistan and certainly they're going
to be Yemenis coming out of the region
too and so I do feel that as a society
we do have a moral responsibility to
help not only in just giving
humanitarian aid but when in bringing
all the people who are seeking asylum in
our country and right now I'll tell you
that the priority if there is priority
being given to refugees it's for men who
have helped the US military in Iraq and
Afghanistan they're given special
immigrant visas called sibs to come to
this country and so they're being
prioritized but there are many other
people from those countries who you know
who need need refuge and somebody needs
to help those families that are stuck in
refugee camps in you know various
countries and so I believe you know some
of the crucial things we need to really
give people a good period of assistance
they need to be housed they need to be
given sustainable jobs and they need to
get English so that they can you know
participate in American society it
should be longer than eight months you
know we need to really restore the kind
of benefits that used to be available
and I also want to say right now in this
year we are at the lowest level of
refugee admissions really in recent
history you know lower than even in 1980
because of the current political regime
in which we're living and this sort of
resistance to bringing immigrants and
refugees into this country although I
must say no refugee has ever committed
an act of terrorism on US soil
no refugee of any kind and so refugees
have been a law-abiding population in
this country and so we can't lump them
in as a sort of you know group of
dangerous people because most of them
have proven that they're not dangerous
and we need to do something to support
those people and that's really what my
book is arguing the kind of conclusion
of my book is a call for sort of justice
if you will for you know Arab refugees
around the world well hopefully that
will come hopefully that will come thank
you for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work Marcia thank
you Marilyn thank you very much for more
information about Professor in Hoorn and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]
you